it's been so long that it's easy to
forget but do you remember
last year
when
the frontline healthcare workers put
aside all concern for themselves put
themselves at risk and did everything
they could to slow the spread and
flatten the curve
they were heroes
they were
the most heroic americans in history the
media compared them favorably to first
responders during the september 11th
attacks
politicians
news people
everybody
they were held out as exemplars of
virtue
people we ought to model our lives after
and who we ought to do everything
everything to protect to express our
gratitude toward
well that was then and this is now and
now they're selfish murderers if they
won't take the fouchy algae which is why
a north carolina-based hospital system
has just announced that it has fired
about 175 of them for refusing to take
this shot
if you think that's bad
just wait just wait if you think it's
bad what they are doing to these sainted
health care workers just wait until you
hear what congress plans to do to you
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
known show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from the right ideas
who says i wonder what michael said that
got the original post taken down this is
my episode yesterday which we'll get to
in just one second i wonder what it was
that michael said they got the original
post taken down probably something that
was completely true that big tech needs
to prevent the libs from hearing great
show anyway thank you very much greatly
appreciate that i feel that my show
yesterday
was a work of art now when you want to
invest in great works of art i would
strongly recommend you check out
masterworks the global lockdowns have
completely disrupted markets you've got
crazy spending from pelosi's house of
representatives from the binding
administration it's only making things
worse the fed is printing trillions of
dollars on congress's infrastructure
bill they're considering printing a
trillion or minting a trillion dollar
coin
doesn't take a genius to see what your
money uh is going to be looking at in
the future and why it needs a safe haven
that's what it needs right now so how
are professional investors preparing for
this nightmare scenario they've already
prepared they've turned to an under the
radar asset class one that's
historically only been available to uh
the professional investor types it's a
real physical asset it's not gold it's
not real estate it's not anything
related to crypto it's actually fine art
yes one of the oldest and most stable
asset classes of all time thanks to a
revolutionary new tech platform you can
finally get access to this exciting six
trillion dollar world early adopters
have already returned 32 on their
investment the wait list keeps getting
longer yesterday by the way was
caravaggio's birthday all right just for
those of you who are into into art lucky
for you they've given me 60 passes to
skip that wait list jump to the front of
the line head to masterworks dot io
slash mk that's
io
mk
previous offers have sold out in hours
don't wait around before deciding to
invest carefully review the important
disclosures at masterworks dot io
disclaimer i have to apologize to people
who went to youtube yesterday to try to
watch my episode i felt it was a pretty
good episode i felt we got a lot of
information out there a lot of
information that people ought to hear
i guess youtube disagrees
because we were impelled
to lose our episode yesterday had to
take down the whole episode
why was that specifically
it is because i was in violation of the
brand new covid
misinformation policy really ought to be
renamed covid information policy from
youtube it just came out yesterday and
we found ourselves in violation of it
and specifically we found ourselves in
violation of this policy because we we
played some clips of those basketball
players
from the nba during the nba media day
uh pointing out or i'm sorry how do i
say this without being without having
this episode taken down the claim that
was made by the basketball players is
that people who get vaccinated again
against covet 19 can still get covid19
and they can still transmit kovid19 and
this was terrible misinformation
see this this violated the policy i have
the policy right here the policy says
that that uh you are not allowed to uh
post any information
well it's a little confusing actually
because you so what i violated was
you're not allowed to post any
information that claims that covid19
vaccines are not effective in preventing
the spread of covet 19. so if you if you
state the claim on on youtube that
people still can get coveted and train
and transmit covid once they get the
vaccine that is in violation of their
policy
so from that rule it would seem the only
thing you're allowed to say is that the
covid vaccines are completely 100
effective at preventing the spread of
covid19
but also but also you're not allowed to
claim
that any medication or vaccination is a
guaranteed protection method for covid19
so
huh let me try to figure i you know i
always thought i was a reasonably clever
guy but i'm not allowed to say that the
vaccines work at stopping the spread of
covid19 but i'm also not allowed to say
that the vaccines don't work at stopping
the spread of covid19 and this is really
really confusing to me because i was
reading nature very well-respected
medical journal or a scientific journal
broadly and
the headline is this is not that long
ago it was a month ago how do vaccinated
people spread delta what the science
says
well hold on youtube just told me
vaccinated people don't spread delta so
i can't they don't spread covet 19 at
all so that's not possible when the
early field data showed that vaccinating
people cuts transmission of kovid
researchers were cautiously optimistic
but they warned that many of those
studies although promising took place
before the fast-spreading delta variant
proliferated worldwide now reports from
various countries seem to confirm what
scientists feared after the variant tore
through india with alarming speed in
april and may delta is more likely than
other variants to spread through
vaccinated people am i allowed to quote
this article am i allowed to quote a
scientific journal on youtube because i
think by quoting the scientific journal
i'm now in violation of the youtube
anti-science policies
anti-science misinformation policies
because the scientists are no longer the
orbiters of the science
some punk idiots at youtube are the
arbiters of the science right is that
what happens it goes on
data from covid19 tests in the united
states
the united kingdom and singapore are
showing that vaccinated people who
become infected with delta soros covid2
can carry as much virus in their nose as
do unvaccinated people this means that
despite the protection offered by
vaccines a proportion of vaccinated
people can pass on delta possibly aiding
its rise that's according to scientists
in nature but according to some
princeton women's studies major who is
writing these policies at youtube that
can't be true so i guess we have to
follow the the 23 year old who graduated
from brown or whatever and studied
critical theory
right over the scientists but it's even
weirder than that it's even weirder than
that because i'm not allowed to say this
and i hope nature doesn't get me taken
down from youtube
because
this new policy from youtube means i
can't even quote the cdc
the director of the cdc dr rochelle
wallensky went on to cnn went on to wolf
blitzer's show
and said
outright
that the vaccine does not
keep you safe
from transmission
what about all the fully vaccinated
people who get the breakthrough
infection can they pass it on could they
pass it on to their children could they
pass the virus on to older people
especially more vulnerable people with
the underlying health conditions
and that's exactly the point that we
made in our guidance so yes they can
with the delta variant and that was the
reason that we changed our guidance last
tuesday um our vaccines are working
exceptionally well they continue to work
well for delta with regard to severe
illness and death they prevent it but
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission so if you're going home to
somebody who has not been vaccinated to
somebody who can't get vaccinated
somebody who might be immunosuppressed
or a little bit uh frail somebody who
has
comorbidities that put them at high risk
i would suggest you wear a mask in
public indoor settings
that's exactly what i said yesterday on
this show that's exactly what those
basketball players said too by the way
but but i'm not even forget the
basketball players for a second i said
on this show yesterday
that
i said
what the director of the cdc said
am i is this video going to come down
from youtube because i played the cdc
director
are they going to say that i'm spreading
scientific misinformation because i
verbatim quote the director of the
center for disease control and
prevention
or quote the scientists in the journal
nature
or
or point out what all of us know which
is that people who have been vaccinated
contract the virus
it happened to a friend of mine just a
month or so ago now listen it's happened
to many friends of mine starting a month
ago and even more recently and it's
happened to all of you as well
but it it actually isn't even about that
look there's a lot of other
questionable claims made in this
document there's one that says you're
not allowed to say that the coven-19
vaccine will contain substances that are
not on the vaccine-ingredient list such
as biological matter from fetuses like
fetal tissue and fetal cell lines
now it is true
the vaccines do not contain fetal tissue
but
aborted fetal cells and the cell lines
derived from them are used in the
development of the mrna vaccines and in
the development and production of the
johnson and johnson vaccines that's
undeniable everyone acknowledges that
but you're not are you or am i allowed
to talk about that i don't know i don't
know what this is really about i think
is it has nothing to do with stopping
slowing the spread of coronavirus or
whatever it obviously has nothing to do
with the science the cdc the new youtube
guidelines
could get the director of the cdc kicked
off of youtube
for spreading scientific misinformation
could get the journal nature
kicked off of youtube if they have a
youtube channel i suspect they don't
what this is about though has nothing to
do with what is the science or what is
misinformation
this has to do with who decides
who decides in a traditional sort of
american sense we decide what our
standards for speech are with some
protections offered by the constitution
in our political tradition
in
the kind of scientific culture the
culture that really exalts science we
would say that the scientists are
greater arbiters of this sort of truth
but in our current big tech tyranny
it's whoever controls the means of
communication
it is a bunch of radical leftist
activists at youtube and the parent
company
google
who control what you can say in your
public square about pressing public
matters pressing political matters
that's what self-government has devolved
to in the big tech tyranny
when you want to protect yourself
against these sort of things against all
the craziness in our politics and our
economy i would strongly recommend you
check out acre gold lots of uncertainty
out there in the markets right now in
our economy in our whole political
system which is why
i think a lot of people are interested
in investing in physical precious metals
specifically gold but you will say
michael but michael
it's very expensive to invest in
physical gold
calm down what if i told you you could
invest for 30 bucks a month michael you
liar don't call me a liar listen listen
up acre has developed this new system
you subscribe to their gold bars when
your gold stash reaches the price of
their gold bars you will discreetly get
acre gold physically at your home and
you can have it and you can enjoy it
they've also got a hundred dollar
subscription to a five gram gold bar
i have really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals and in acre
gold specifically go to get acre gold
dot getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acre is giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's getacregold.com
knowles you think it's bad what google
is doing to us that is bad it is bad
it's really bad when a bunch of
dishonest people
dishonest capricious people
are controlling speech in a republic
that's really really bad
but
you're not just seeing this in the realm
of speech from big technology you're
seeing this throughout the society
there's a report right now
that joe biden is threatening to fire
border agents not just the border agents
who were using the imaginary whips on
haitian migrants which did not actually
happen
but and by the way which even the
left-wing media will admit did not
happen now
but
a joe biden is threatening to fire
border agents if they don't take the
fouchy algae if they don't take the
vaccine
house judiciary
gop just claimed
on tuesday
that a whistleblower came forward and
said the dhs has notified u.s border
patrol agents that they will be
terminated if they do not receive the
fauci algae
the house gop wrote whistleblower
alleges border patrol agents have been
given official notice that they must be
fully vaccinated by november
2021 or face
termination
so a full vaccination
right now is considered two shots of the
mrna vaccine or one shot of the johnson
and johnson vaccine
but actually our wonderful public health
officials up to and including dr foucher
now saying that actually doesn't really
constitute full
vaccination that actually a booster is
going to be needed for full vaccination
that that is coming down the pike sooner
rather than later so these poor border
patrol agents i don't know what's going
to happen to them they really they
really seem to be getting it from every
single angle what about all the rest of
us what about people who are just
working for some company who now because
of joe biden's mandate to the
occupational safety and health
administration if they work for a
company that has more than 100 employees
will have to
take the fauchiachi or they could lose
their job or their employer will be
fined
initially the employer and we talked
about this here at daily wire because we
are not going to comply with this stupid
mandate we are going to fight it tooth
and nail we strongly suspect it will be
shot down in court we suspect that the
biden administration knows it'll be shot
down in court but they're they're just
basically
twisting everybody's arm to get the
vaccine already so that by the time it's
struck down in court it doesn't matter
so we're not complying with this we're
opening ourselves up
to what we believed at the daily wire
was pretty significant financial
liability because
initially the fines for violating the
covid vaccine mandate were 14 000
per violation that's a lot of money
you know we do well we appreciate
everyone's subscriptions we appreciate
our wonderful advertisers but 14 grand
per violation for a big company is a lot
of money
well the house democrats just snuck a
provision into the three and a half
trillion dollar reconciliation bill that
would raise those fines
from fourteen thousand dollars to
seventy thousand dollars per violation
that's not the best of it
willful quote-unquote and repeat
quote-unquote violations of the osha
regulations
could cost businesses
seven
hundred thousand dollars per incident
we do well we're the fastest growing
conservative media company in america
the shows do very well we appreciate all
our wonderful audience members we
obviously the company is doing so well
that big tech is trying to smush us
because we're getting the message out to
too
too well
but even for us seven hundred thousand
dollars per incident
with a company that has hundreds of
employees
per incident per that that's enough to
bankrupt anybody
that's enough to twist anybody's arm now
by the way we're still not going to
comply
so
i hope
i hope we get to stay on the air a nice
long time
but they are dead serious about this
they are going to force you any way they
can the left admitted that a direct flat
out mandate from the federal government
was probably not going to work and it
was probably not legal
but
they're
working with a lot of workarounds
through the administrative state now in
collusion with the house democrats that
can really cause a lot of pain it's hard
to sleep easy at night with that kind of
stuff and by the way when you want to
sleep easy i would strongly recommend
you check out bowlin branch when i was a
young man a bachelor in my wayward youth
in my stupidity i would buy cheap bed
sheets
i would do this because i thought oh who
cares it's not a big deal i'll be asleep
anyway
you spend something like a third of your
life sleeping
get the best get the invest in the best
for your bed sheets for
these basic things about your life with
bowling branch you're going to get the
best
uncompromising comfort
the best-selling 100 organic cotton
signature hem cheats their cloud weight
super soft satin weave gets softer with
every single wash crafted to the highest
standards of attention to detail from
sourcing to packaging these guys are
amazing
i've been sleeping on bowling branch
since before i got married when we
upgraded the size of our bed when we got
married basically first thing my wife
says to me is we need to get we need to
get the bowling branch we need the
bigger bowling branch sheets to
experience an entirely new standard of
comfort visit bowlingbranch.com get 15
off your first set of sheets with promo
code michael that's b-o-l-l and branch
dot com promo code michael
now the house democrats are
going to try to raise a bunch of money
by fining conservative companies who
don't want to force their employees to
take the experimental drug for the virus
that does not statistically pose a
particularly grave threat to the vast
majority of people
but they're
they're still not going to raise enough
money to deal with the looming debt
crisis so you know
if you've been watching the news perhaps
you've heard about this the u.s faces a
debt crisis we don't want to default on
our debt this issue has cropped up a
number of times in recent years
and uh so there is such a thing as a
debt ceiling and then congress goes in
and raises the debt ceiling so we can
raise more and more and more debt and we
won't default okay
and and then sometimes the republicans
don't want to raise the debt ceiling so
they had a big fight on this during the
obama years during the tea party years
now there's a question what do you do if
the congress won't raise the debt
ceiling what do you do if the united
states is about to default on its debt
well there is
there is a
seemingly crazy idea that's been around
for some time it's right now it's being
pushed by rashida talib a radical
leftist in the house of representatives
who is saying well we don't even need
congress to to
raise the debt ceiling
the president has the authority to mint
a one trillion dollar coin because of
this one provision of the law that
allows you to mint a platinum coin of
any denomination you can just mint a
trillion dollar coin
and then there there you go then you can
deal with the debt and and you don't
need to worry about it and it's a it's a
bit of an accounting gimmick but is this
how we're going to deal with our our
spending problems in this country we're
going to just have the president mint
trillion dollar coins well actually the
idea wasn't just proposed by rashida
talib it was suggested years ago by
barack obama there was this theory that
i had the authority to just issue this
uh
through the the mint i could just issue
this massive
a trillion dollar coin a trillion dollar
commemorative coin commemorative coin
and then on that basis we could try to
pay off uh u.s uh treasuries
and
it was a very realistic possibility that
uh we couldn't get the votes for that
and we couldn't get uh
those debts rolled over and we would be
in a situation where
technically we're in default and at that
point you were in
uncharted territory
at that point you were in uncharted
territory i guess that's true and there
are some economists who believe that if
you mint a trillion dollar coin like
we're a failing government of zimbabwe
or something like that that actually the
effect won't be that bad if it's just a
week or something or even if we default
if it's just like a week or so it's not
going to be a big deal we'll deal with
the accounting error or forget about it
who cares
regardless of the legality of this
regardless even of the potential
repercussions
this is not how a free people
governs itself this is not how a serious
country deals with its fiscal problems
the way that we're supposed to deal with
that is congress
is supposed to hold the purse strings
remember that's what they taught us in
schoolhouse rock i am a bill up on
capitol hill and all that congress has
the purse strings
congress decides how much money to spend
congress decides how much how much debt
it's willing to tolerate
and then the government runs itself and
that way the executive runs the
government according to to that system
but that's not how it works in our
country anymore
we're now a very frivolous country that
doesn't take any of this stuff seriously
least of all self-government
it is very hard to say that we govern
ourselves in this country if we
have no say over how much money we're
spending
how we're spending that money through
our elected representatives and
if we have
if we don't have a say period because
some
tyrants at google have have seized the
reins of all of our speech in america
and they determine who gets to say what
and who gets to say true things and who
gets to even quote scientific
authorities
and who gets to label that scientific
misinformation
obama i can't get angry at obama for
suggesting the trillion dollar coin
it's sort of the logical next step
isn't it and barack obama who was a
radical president
compared to his predecessors barack
obama seems positively tame
now
barack he does he does right now you've
got the biden administration permitting
untold numbers of illegal aliens to
flood into our country well over a
million i mean what we're at least at
1.2 or 1.3 million so far i think we're
actually significantly higher than that
now barack obama was not not exactly a
responsible steward of our national
borders barack obama permitted lots and
lots of foreign nationals to flood into
our country as well
the democrats have encouraged this sort
of thing historically because they think
it suits their political advantage
but even barack obama
is coming out looking at the crisis on
our southern border and saying this sort
of thing
cannot go on
there are even some democrats democrats
who are not currently
you know
as involved in the political scene like
like a former president and democrats
who come from more moderate districts
who are looking at this and saying you
know
this is a big
threat to the country
radical as we want to be you simply
you simply cannot have open
totally open borders forever my question
to them is and seriously i'm not even
joking
why not
you know
i have another question that involves
the word why not it's why are you not
getting fit why are you not getting into
shape why are you not protecting
yourself and getting more energy when
you want to do that i would strongly
recommend planet fitness are you feeling
stressed are you feeling flabby are you
feeling fat and tired and lethargic and
like you're just not doing what you
should be doing filling your full
potential
change that today okay work out your
stress get back to feeling great at
planet fitness join the judgment-free
zone today for just 10 bucks a month 10
bucks a month get a ton of cardio and
strength equipment in clean and spacious
clubs really really great stuff check it
out you get the crowd meter in the free
pf app best time to visit 10 bucks a
month you can't beat that 2 000 plus
locations today
see the club for details this october
not only will backstage be live and on
stage at the famous ryman auditorium
right here in nashville we're also
giving one lucky member a chance to win
two vip tickets to get front row seats
and not just that the winner will
receive a 1500 gift card to cover travel
expenses a meet and greet with the
backstage hosts and more tickets for the
ryman show sold out already they sold
out in about 40 minutes or something so
thank you to all of you who
got tickets and i'm sorry for those of
you who were not able to get tickets
right now
you do still have a chance to get in on
the action join one of our membership
plans with the code backstage for 25 off
your membership if you're already a
member you will be automatically entered
to win hurry though because today is the
last day to enter we'll be right back
with a lot more
even barack obama is looking at the
untold numbers of foreign nationals
flooding across our southern border and
saying you can't
just have
open borders
immigration is tough it always has been
because
on the one hand
uh i think
we are naturally
uh
a a people that wants to help others at
the same time
we're a nation state we have borders the
idea that we can just have open borders
is something that uh i think
as a practical matter is is
unsustainable
okay interesting how he phrases this by
the way
the idea that you can just have open
borders is as a practical matter
unsustainable
so what he's saying here is i i kind of
wish that we could have open borders oh
it would be great oh wouldn't that be so
great but as a practical matter it's
unsustainable so at least we all agree
with obama on the last part i don't
think it would be great if we could have
open borders i think it would be a very
bad thing i think would be very
uncivilized and undignified and unjust
to the american people who formerly in a
past age had the right to say who gets
to come into their country and become
americans and and participate in their
political system we used to have that
right we don't really have that right
anymore
barack obama doesn't seem to have a
problem with us losing that right but he
just says as a practical matter
this is not going to work
why not
why not why won't this work
this is what the democrats have been
doing for a very long time
well
because it is
increasing it is diluting people's votes
right that's what the democrats want to
do well because it's increasing
uh social instability right that's what
the democrats want to do well because
it's changing the character of of the
american nation and culture right that's
what democrats want to do why why won't
that seems to be working just fine for
them not no it's not working fine for
the country
not working fine for the rule of law
but it seems to be working out just fine
for democrats
now
i think as a practical matter what
obama's worried about is that swing
state dems are going to get thrown out
because the american people broadly
don't like this thing there have been
polls to show that the american people
want to drastically reduce not just
illegal but legal immigration as well
just too much we just take in way too
many people okay it's not
nothing against the people who are
pouring into the country we just can't
take in everybody and we're taking in
way too many right now
so when is this going to end well jen
saki spokesman at the white house
nearest we're going to get to hearing
from joe biden says that the border
crisis will continue
until we completely overhaul the
immigration system the white house
believes that and the president believes
that our immigration system is
incredibly broken and we saw a surge
we've certainly seen a surge of migrants
come to the border recently we saw a
surge back in 2019 we saw a surge back
in 2014 until we fix the system and we
have a more
effective and operational immigration
system until we have an asylum
processing system that works at the
border we're going to continue to see
cyclical challenges like this
and we've seen them over dem
across democratic and republican
presidents so our objective continues to
be um not just addressing obviously uh
the challenges we saw in del rio last
week but working with congress to get
immigration reform passed so we can fix
the broken system and ensure we can have
a better operational process moving
forward
this is a pretty clever way to to frame
it it's not true but it's a clever way
to frame it
her basic claim is the immigration
system is broken
and it needs to be fixed in a very
significant way
we all agree with that we all agree with
that that's the kind of talking point
you can hear and say oh i agree yeah jen
saki's right yeah of course immigration
reform yeah we need immigration reform
the system obviously is not working
right that's what just look at what's
happening at the border so yeah we need
to reform it
what do we need to reform
what is not working
if you ask
some democrats
both the radical left base and the
cynical operatives
though not the kind of middle-of-the-pac
democrats the you're just average
democrat voter in the middle of the
country
if you ask them
they will say the problem with our
immigration system is we don't take
enough people in
if you ask republicans or independents
or conservatives what is problem with
our immigration system they will say
either we don't take the right people in
or we take way too many people in or
some combination thereof
so
this simple straightforward matter of
we need to reform immigration it
actually means opposite things right the
the devil's in the details here
jen saki is really claiming yeah we need
to take way more people into the country
well if that's what immigration reform
means i'm against it
i'm for immigration reform that
drastically reduces the number of people
who get to come into the country to
bring it even
somewhere closer to what other countries
in the world take in
or not many multiples or even order of
magnitude higher than what other
countries in the world take in
right
or or and hear me out
we can just leave the system exactly as
it is and enforce the law why can't we
do that
it seems to me
that democrats encourage
foreigners to flood across the border
and you've heard
multiple democrat candidates for
president including the two people in
this administration biden and kamala at
various times saying come on over surge
get on over here come on they do that to
create the problem that creates the
impression for a need for comprehensive
immigration reform that's only going to
exacerbate the problem the problem being
way too many people from only a handful
of countries coming into the country
every year
so
here's my here's my alternative to
immigration reform
don't do anything
well what are you are you michael but
michael are you
going to allow
millions of illegal aliens
just to live in the shadows
yeah sure why not
see that's that seems like actually
pretty nice isn't that seems actually
quite generous what we should do is
deport them all because they have no
right to be here they broke the first
thing they did was break our laws
so
the three options we have are
deport them
or
give them all citizenship and encourage
and incentivize this kind of lawless
behavior and fundamentally change our
political system and undermine the right
of the american people to govern
themselves
or just let them kind of live in the
shadows until we figure out a way to
enforce the law and deport the ones we
can deport
that that seems like the most reasonable
solution of all why don't we just do
that
just yeah sure what are you you're going
to do nothing
yeah i don't it's not that i want to do
nothing i want i actually want to do
something significant i want to enforce
the law
but i don't want any big bill
with any
panel of democrats and some squish
republicans who say that the most
conservative thing we can possibly do is
give voting rights to tens of millions
of foreign nationals who are
statistically
almost certain
in almost every case to vote for
democrats yeah i
yeah i'm against that i'm against that
whatever the opposite of that is that's
what i'm that's what i'm for
speaking of our border patrol and our
immigration system
remember that lie that came out
some days ago that border patrol
mounted on horseback were whipping
haitian immigrants
they were whipping them and we looked at
that on this show is being pushed by
basically the entire mainstream media
we were looking at that and said that's
not true that's not true i guess you
know i'm really glad that right now big
tech is just focused on
spreading
public health propaganda because
if if they had been focused on spreading
immigration propaganda then they
probably would have taken us down for
observing the fact that the border
patrol agents were not using whips
against
the haitian illegal aliens
well it turns out that we were right and
the establishment media were wrong
and they were not using whips and they
were not using chains and now even the
establishment media themselves are
admitting this here's jake tapper
calling out
a little little late for my liking but
jake tapper at least finally
acknowledging the truth and calling out
the health secretary or the the homeland
security secretary mayorkas
some of the initial descriptions of
those images were just patently false
there's now video out there that
provides more context uh having seen the
video uh are you certain that there was
actually wrongdoing
have you because there's now it would
seem it's pretty clear that actually the
initial reports that we were told were
not true we were going to play a clip of
brian stelter
who made this same point brian stelter
on cnn came out and he said you know the
initial reports they just weren't true
and actually they weren't using whip so
i had that i was i watched that clip
last night that clip has basically been
scrubbed from the internet by the time
that my editors today went to grab that
clip and put it into the show it was
gone
why was that was that because of cnn
didn't like it up there or maybe was it
because big tech didn't like it up there
very possibly very very possibly
knowing what they do knowing what they
do to this very show for spreading true
information wouldn't be surprised that
on the rare occasion that cnn says
something that's true
big tech would take that down but i
don't know all i know is it's gone but
ryan stelter did it too so i want to
give him credit
now
this is uh pretty funny that two people
on cnn would come out and and call out
the media for spreading and stelter was
doing this in particular he said calling
out the media for spreading this
misinformation that
the the border patrol agents were using
whips on the haitian migrants because
cnn was spreading a ton of that
misinformation
who was doing it chris cuomo
shared report reports of people being
beaten said the images smack of a bygone
era of slavery
no evidence that the even the border
patrol reigns touched anybody aaron
burnett also on cnn said quote video of
border patrol agents on horseback
confronting haitian migrants with whips
that was on september 21st on out front
just a complete lie also on cnn cnn's
white house correspondent john harwood
condemned those horrendous videos of
agents on horseback swinging lariats or
whips or whatever they are at least john
harwood is admitting he has no idea what
he's talking about by saying or whatever
or whatever but he mentions the whips
just a complete lie from the cnn white
house correspondent christian amanpour
who drew clavin refers to as christian
i'm a poor journalist rightly so
interviews an activist who said that the
photos of the agents quote using reigns
as whips against migrants they were not
only startling and shocking but it's
triggering again
no evidence that that happened cnn
anchor laura jarrett misled viewers
about quote disturbing new video of
border patrol agents on horseback trying
to stop migrants from crossing the
border into the u.s look at that using
whips that was on early start on
september 21st complete lie jake tapper
himself actually
said he didn't quite go so far as to
mention the whips but he said border
patrol agents are aggressively
threatening migrants and aggressively
confronting haitian migrants i guess
i guess that could be true in the sense
that law enforcement is supposed to be
aggressive against criminals i guess
that's the point but he seems to be
framing it in such a way that's pretty
silly in a way that he's actually kind
of condemning now
and cnn's april ryan did the same thing
referring to the reigns or whips
whatever right again admitting she knows
nothing but still using whips so
i'm glad that cnn that tapper and
stelter are coming out and saying yeah
the media's got to stop stop this kind
of stuff
well before you cues anyone else take a
look at yourself fellas because cnn is
the chief purveyor of that kind of fake
news
these people just must not hear
themselves they must not hear themselves
don lemon on cnn i i i think don lemon
might be a talking point slot machine i
think we might have just hit the jackpot
listen there are many good things about
political parties and many not so good
things about political parties but i
just don't believe in voting because
someone is a republican or someone as a
democrat i vote on what they what they
have done what they will do what their
records are and what they stand for so
having said that there is one political
party in this country that is working on
reality
and that is a democratic party but even
in that they're not governing very well
at the moment they're not performing the
duty of being good politicians in the
moment they don't see the urgency of
what's happening across the country with
voting rights what's happening
the urgency of of um what's happening
with the the big lie
this they are still operating on
thinking that oh everything is
normal
you know we've we've gotta play politics
as usual it's not politics as usual what
is happening on the right is not
politics as usual and what's happening
on the right is not right it's wrong
and they they should pay the
consequences for what they're doing to
our democracy the damage they're doing
to our democracy and the damage they're
doing to this republic
it's not just that what what don lemon
said is not true
it's that it's meaningless that's the
problem the meaninglessness
don lemon comes out on cnn
and
he
goes on this rant about
the political parties
and
partisanship and normal and how we're
not living in normal times and
republicans are a threat to our
democracy
and the i mean we can go through point
by point and we will very briefly but
my issue with it is not
it's not his partisanship he's obviously
a democrat it's not his ideology he's
obviously a leftist
so much as his mindlessness
i have friends
who are liberal friends
friends of mine for many many years
family members
beloved family members
who will who will do this sort of
thing i it doesn't bother me if you
don't know anything about politics it
doesn't it doesn't by think bless it or
you if you can just sort of do your job
and
watch sports and hang out with your kids
and just haven't have a nice time that's
that's great good for you no i don't
think people need to be in the
nitty-gritty of politics all the time
but what does bother me
is when people without doing any work or
any sort of research or giving any real
thought whatsoever to a political issue
mindlessly just spout off these kinds of
slogans that's a big problem that's a
far greater threat to our democracy
than any of this stuff
first thing don lemon says is look i
don't i don't like partisanship okay
parties have their place but i don't
just vote for someone because they're a
democrat okay i vote for the person not
the party the person
what does that mean what does that mean
i don't i don't vote for
the person i vote for
what the person is going to do and what
the person is going to do is informed by
how that person views the world and how
that person views the world is going to
align almost perfectly with a political
party
i vote for the person at the party means
i like the person's haircut i like the
way they talk i like the i i think that
person is attractive
really if you had to choose between the
two you should vote for the party not
the person
because at least the party tells you
something about the ideas what the
person thinks what they're gonna do
the person that's just
flattery it's just superficial but for
the person not the party so okay so
you're gonna vote for uh what under what
circumstances don lemon would you vote
for a republican
probably never he's probably being
disingenuous but i guess he could say it
just makes him feel good to seem like
he's really open-minded but i guess he
would say he votes for a republican when
the republican wants to do a bunch of
democrat things well then he's just
practically a democrat
okay then he goes on he says democrats
aren't paying attention to what the
republicans are doing with voting rights
what about with voting right it's just
such a vague slogan with voting rights
with with the big lie
with the big what is the big lie
don lemon doesn't even know what the
phrase the big lie means the big lie
which is how democrats describe
donald trump's perfectly reasonable
observation that there were some
strange shenanigans with the 2020
presidential election uh the big lie it
was a phrase that it refers to the nazis
right this is what uh this is why
they're using that phrase is to compare
republicans to nazis what they don't
realize is
hitler used the phrase the big lie
in
mein kampf
to accuse the jews of telling a lie
about a german general as pertained to
world war one so when
when you accuse someone of using the big
lie you are actually putting yourself in
the place of hitler and putting your
opponents in the place of the jews again
a point lost on people who don't
pay any attention to these things and
who are not thoughtful and who are not
particularly educated like don lemon
okay then he goes on this is what
they're doing to our democracy first of
all we don't live in a democracy we
don't the american government is not
supposed to be a democrat it's a it's a
form of democracy it involves some
democratic elements it includes some
non-democratic elements as well
and ironically the people most opposed
to our democracy at the moment seem to
be democrats who believe that laws on
for instance abortion should be made
from the judges that that laws on
coronavirus mandates should be pushed
from the executive agency that who
believe that
all these sorts of decisions that
marriage itself ought to be redefined
against the will of the people by
certain judges all of these sorts of
things
the only party
resembling an oligarchic party in the
united states would be the democratic
party
absolute
mind do not
do not do this yourself i don't i don't
need to warn you
you're a thoughtful person
do not do not pair with these mindless
slogans it's very very embarrassing
but there's a clip going viral right now
that actually made me think about this
it's a clip going viral from 2014 but
it's making the runs again of a guy on
cnbc
who is
interviewing an irish businessman
and
he is astounded to learn
that ireland does not use as its
currency the pound sterling ireland uses
the euro so this is an expert guy anchor
type on cnbc the financial news channel
and he is shocked to learn
what kind of money ireland uses
what has the
weaker euro meant in terms of tourism
yes so i i think um
ireland's a very globalized economy so
we looked at what's happening here as
much as we do to what's happening in
europe and we looked at what's happening
in groups anyway
we have euros you have euros in ireland
yes
why wouldn't we have euros in ireland
huh how do you i'd use the pound no we
we've had the euro for some time and
we're very happy with it what about
scotland i was using scottish uh
scottish pounds yeah so they use
sterling
they use sterling they use starting but
we use euro yeah what
why would you do that
why wouldn't we do that
why didn't scotland no wonder they want
to break we're not um you're right next
to uh we're we're very close but uh and
entirely separated sort of the same
same island isn't it
and in the north of ireland they they
have sterling but they do we use europe
all right we turn now to a genius expert
money numbers guy man on the tv for uh
commentary uh what is your thought on uh
this this development in ireland duh
they use euro
you know they why but they're close to
england
wow really insightful commentary mr tv
smart newsman the reason i bring this up
the reason that i think that this is
going viral right now
is because
we are recognizing
increasingly that the people who claim
authority and who claim that we follow
whatever they say and who claim to be
the very super serious adults in the
room don't know anything they don't they
don't know very much at all these are
the people who have gotten things so so
wrong in the public health establishment
in the politics in the news media and
most especially at big technology the
greatest purveyors of misinformation
there are out there
i'm michael knowles i hope i see you
tomorrow and i hope you get this episode
today we'll see you then
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show
progressives threaten to kill the
bipartisan infrastructure bill unless
moderates go along with their budget
busting plans joe biden sneaks a massive
fine into the democratic budget bill for
businesses that don't force vaccines on
their workers and the biden military
infrastructure finally admits joe
biden's enormous afghanistan screw-up
that's today on the bench spiral show
give it a listen